اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام في هذه التغطيه
المستمره ضمن الحصاد في الوقت الذي
احاديثكم فيه تستمر اعمال البحث والانقاذ
والاغاثه وتتفاعل تداعيات زلزال تركيا
وسوريا في
شمال غرب ولايه غازي عنتاب وغيرها تتواصل
اعمال البحث عن ناجين تحت الانقاض في
اليوم الثامن للزلزال المدمر بعض المناطق
ما زالت تشهد انتشال احياء يرزقون
وهذه الصور تاتينا من معبر باب السلام على
الحدود بين تركيا وريف حلب الشمالي المعبر
يفترض ان يكون مدخلا لمساعدات للمتضررين
في شمال سوريا من زلزال الاثنين الماضي
وهذه الصور تردنا لمبنى الامم المتحده في
نيويورك حيث يعقد مجلس الامن جلسه مغلقه
لبحث الوضع في سوريا وتركيا على ضوء
الزلزال الذي تراه ضربهما بعنف فجر السادس
من الشهر الجاري
[موسيقى]
وفي مواضيع الحصاد هذه الليله
بعد اسبوع من سجلات عرقله وصول المساعدات
الى منكوبي الزلزال بسوريا مجلس الامن
يبحث في جلسه مغلقه نسق الاستجابه الدوليه
تدعو لفتح معبرين جديدين لايصال
الاحتياجات الاساسيه ومن البرلمان
الاوروبي دعوات للامم المتحده لاقامه جسر
جويا عاجل
وفي الشمال السوري الاف المشردين في ريفاي
حلب وادلب يواجهون في العراء شحا
المساعدات وتعثر الاغاثه ودرجات حراره تحت
الصفر ومع مشهد كارثه واسعه النطاق
المنشات الصحيه تواجه اعباء غير مسبوقه
والصليب الاحمر يقول ان الحاجه الى
المساعده الطارئه في سوريا بلغت اعلى
مستوياتها منذ 12 عاما
وفي تركيا انتشال احياء من تحت الانقاض
بعد اكثر من 180 ساعه على الكارثه ورغم
تضاؤل فرص العثور على احياء فرق انقاذ
محليه ودوليه تكثف جهودها وتسابق الزمن
وتقارير تقدر خسائر زلزال تركيا باكثر من
84 مليار دولار
اذا بعد اسبوع على زلزال يحل في المركز
السادس كاكثر الكوارث الطبيعيه فتكا خلال
مئه عام باتت ملامح الكارثه في تركيا
وسوريا واضحه اكثر من 36 الف قتيل وعشرات
الاف الجرحى ودمار واسع النطاق الماساه
ابعاد كثيره انسانيه واجتماعيه واقتصاديه
ونفسيه ايضا الفاجعه وتداعياتها باتت على
طاوله مجلس الامن الدولي وسط تعهدات
بالمساعده من المجتمع الدولي يؤمل ان
تتحول الى واقع على الارض نتابع مشهد
الكارثه مع دخولها الاسبوع الثاني في
تقرير فاطمه التريكه
يصغر الحزن مع الوقت اما الكارثه فتكبر
وهؤلاء حزنهم محمول على كارثه تتقاذفهم
الام الفقد واهوال العيش فيناظرون عند
الانقاض طللا من لحم ومه في احد الايام
تخيل شاعر ما حدث لبنايه سكنيه ابتلعتها
الارض بقنبله فراغيه فراح يحكي عن سيده
تحت الارض تصنع القهوه وزوج يطالع صحيفه
تخيل حياه لا يراد محوها فمعسى تكون ذاكره
الجالسين فوق الانقاض الوان الاغطيه
وملابس النوم وتمنيات ليله سعيده لم تكتمل
خطط اليوم التالي المتحوله املا شحيحا
بعوده كانها قادمه من السماء
في اليوم الثامن الاف الجثامين لم تخرج
لتدفن ولم يؤخذ قرار نهائي بوقف البحث مع
استمرار رصد اثر لحياه هنا او هناك خصوصا
في تركيا حيث اخرج طفل وامراه مسنه
للخارجين كانه عمر جديد ولذوي المفقودين
انتظار قاتل لا يسكن بغير التسليم باقدار
الله وسننه الماضيه
بعد اسبوع لم يتغير في المشهد سوى زياده
عدد الموتى وهم يقتربون من اربعين الفا في
تركيا وسوريا
وتتحول الجهود اكثر نحو اغاثه الاحياء في
تركيا نزوح كبير من الولايات العشر
المنكوبه باتجاه الشمال ونداءات لتامين
الماوى والغذاء كاولويه للمنكوبين اما في
تلك البقعه المنسيه في شمال غرب سوريا
هناك حيث المخذولون والمتركون باعتراف
الامم المتحده فيتصاعد الالم ودعوات
الانقاذ لاربعه ملايين شخص وقد بحت
الاصوات تطلب الغوث فيدخل قليل شاحنات
للامم المتحده وفرق انقاذ عربيه لكن
الانكشاف الاكبر تمثل في تعامل العالم مع
تلك البقعه الجغرافيه وكانها تائهه لا
يعرف اين تحسب ولا كيف تدار لها معابر مع
تركيا تخضع لاليه دوليه ومعابر داخليه مع
مناطق سيطره النظام ولكل دوله كبيره مبعوث
فهذا مبعوث امامي واخر امري وثالث الماني
يدعون لادخال المساعدات ومع ذلك لا يدخل
سوى القليل لقد انتظرت الاسره الدوليه
اسبوعا لتفكر في اجتماع لمجلس الامن من
اجل غوثهم وحل مشكله المعابر المبهمه
بينما الاف تحت الانقاض وجرحى بلا علاج
ومشردون بلا ماوى
تقول المندوبه الامريكيه في الامم المتحده
ان الاهالي هناك يعتمدون علينا وقد فاتها
ربما انهم من يومهم الاول لم يجدوا غير
يدهم ليصفقوا بها لكن بدا هشا ومخاتلا ذاك
الاتكاء
في اليوم الثامن يسترجع كثيرون ثواني
الرعب مثل فاصل بين حياتين ستتكرر الايام
في تعدادها وتمضي الجرافات قريبا لرفع
الردم واخراج الجثث والرهان على احتواء
تداعيات الكارثه بعدما ظهرت نتيجه
الامتحان الانساني بسقوط مدون للاسره
الدوليه في ذاك المكان من بلاد تدعى سوريا
ينضم الينا من معبر باب السلامه في ريف
حلب مراسل الجزيره عمر الحوراني مرحبا بك
عمر ماذا عن الوضع عند هذا المعبر وسط
المناشدات بفتح المزيد من المعابر بين
تركيا والشمال السوريه لادخالي مساعدات
بشكل اكبر
نعم بدايه هذه المساعدات التي دخلت هي
قليله جدا مقارنه بحجم الماساه ومساحه
الماسه مساحه المنطقه التي ضربها هذا
الزلزال واعداد المتضررين فنتحدث عن دخول
عشرات السيارات لاسيما بالارقام 52 سياره
من معبر باب الهوى ست سياره سبع سته
سيارات من معبر باب الحمام ومن هنا 27
سياره دخلت من هذا المعبر وهذه
الشاحنات كانت تحمل معدات طبيه بالاضافه
الى الشاحنات التي دخلت من هذا المعبر
تحمل 600 خيمه بالاضافه الى 2000 في
بالاضافه الى 2000 بطانيه وهذه المساعدات
دخلت ليتم توزيعها على المتضررين هنا في
شمال سوريا لكن نتحدث عن اعداد كبيره من
المتضررين الاف العائلات تفترش الطرقات
كنا نشاهدهم خلال الفتره الماضيه عند
تجولنا في شمال سوريا متواجدين بشكل كبير
على الطرقات وفي السيارات لا يتوفر لهم
حتى الان الماوى مع المناشدات
لاسراع في ايجاد ماوى لهذه العائلات التي
تضررت هناك بحسب الائتلاف
ائتلاف المعارض هناك 1700 مبنى تدمر بشكل
كامل هناك اكثر من خمسه الاف مبنى هي ايله
للسقوط وسكان هذه المباني هم يباتون
ليلتهم خارج المساكن فهم اذا بحاجه الى
ماوى بحاجه الى غذاء بالاضافه الى حاجتهم
الى مستلزمات طبيه وما زال هناك حاجه
مستمره الى ادخال معدات لكي لرفع الان مع
ضعف بهذه المعدات هنا هذا الامر
ظهر خلال الايام الاولى وقد كما تحدث رئيس
الائتلاف قال بان نقص هذه المعدات زاد من
عدد الوفيات وذلك خلال مؤتمر الصحفي الذي
عقده اليوم هنا في منطقه جنديرس وتحدث
وقال بانه نقص
المعدات تسبب في زياده في عدد الوفيات كما
انه يعني قال بان الامم المتحده يعني
ارسلت المساعدات الى النظام فيما فيما
امتنعت عن ارسالها الى شمال غرب سوريا
وايضا تحدث عن ان هناك اعداد
متزايده في اعداد الضحايا وبان الضحايا في
شمال غرب سوريا تجاوزت
4,200 شخص قضى وجراء هذا الزلزال اذا
نتحدث منطقه منكوبه بشكل كامل لكن ما زاد
من نكبه هذه المنطقه انها منطقه اساسا
يسكنها نازحون تهجروا من المحافظات
السوريه اي ان هناك اناسا سابقا كانوا في
المخيمات فاجتمع
منكوبول حرب مع منكوبيه مع منكوبي الزلازل
هنا في هذه المنطقه وهذا الامر ادى الى ان
خيام يسكنها نازحين
الان يستقبلون يعني عددا من العائلات التي
تهجرت جراء هذا
الزلزاء الجرار هذا الزلزال هناك تبعات
كبيره
لهذا الزلزال ان كانت على الصعيد عدم توفر
الماوى وان كانت على صعيد قله الغذاء في
هذه المنطقه هذه المنطقه كانت سابقا بحاجه
الى غذاء مستمر وتقديم المساعدات عبر
الحدود بشكل مستمر لكن هذا الزلزال ضعف
هذه الحاجه
الحوراني من معبر باب السلامه في ريفي حلب
ينضم الينا الان من غازي عنتاب مراسل
الجزيره المعتز حسن المعتز مرحبا بك قربنا
من المشهد في غازي عنتاب ما الذي يحصل على
الارض في هذه المرحله
[موسيقى]
عموما هو وضع متشابه القصص هي نفسها هناك
العديد من القصص الانسانيه التي نسمعها
خلال النهار اليوم خلال الجوله التي قمنا
فيها في عموم مدينه نوردا كان هناك واضحا
ربما تاثر المباني بشكل كبير في هذه
المدينه وايضا كان هناك سعي لتامين المسكن
للذين هم خارج بيوتها بجراء هذا الزلزال
كان هناك تجهيز للاراضي من اجل اقامه
المخيمات وهذه المخيمات هي من الخيام التي
تقوم بنشرها منظمه اداره الطوارئ والكوارث
التركيه وايضا الهلال الاحمر التركي لكن
ايضا كان هناك تجهيز لمناطق من اجل
الحاويات المعدنيه والتي هي تشكل ربما نوع
من الاقامه افضل من الخيام في ظل هذه
الظروف
البارده كان هناك ايضا استخدام لربما حسب
مشاهدنا استخدام للكلاب في بعض المواقع
خصوصا في تلك المواقع التي تشهد مساحه
دمار واسعه وذلك من اجل تحديد الجثث في
المناطق واين هي موجوده من اجل سرعه
الوصول وانتشالي هذه الجسد الجثث كل هذا
طبعا وهو في اليوم الثامن من هذا الزلزال
اشكرك اذا من نورداغ مراسل الجزيره
المعتزله حسن
ما زالت ازمه المساعدات ودخولها الى
المناطق المنكوبه في الشمال السوري محل
جدل ونقاش وتفاعل دولي وعلى وقع
الانتقادات لما يوصف بتقصير المجتمع
الدولي يجتمع مجلس الامن الدولي
محنه فاخرى ما ابقته الحرب نسفه الزلزال
ترتبط المحنتان ايضا في كون الاولى اوجدت
واقعا في الشمال السوري عقد تبعات التاليه
حتى قبل ان تهتز الارض هنا كان ما يزيد
على اربعه ملايين شخص بتقدير الامم
المتحده بحاجه الى المساعدات والان تتعثر
جهود ايصال ما يلزم من مساعدات انسانيه
الى المتضررين من الزلزال في حينها ودون
عوائق
الامم المتحده نفسها تقر بالفشل في ايصال
المساعدات الحيويه مع ان لديها اليه واضحه
في هذا الشان
ففي مناطق سيطره المعارضه السوريه
المحاذيه لتركيا مع بران حدوديان رئيسيه
هما باب الهوى فير في ادلب وقد جدد مجلس
الامن الشهر الماضي التفويض الامميه لدخول
المساعدات عبر سته اشهر اخرى
ومعبر باب السلامه في ريف حلب المغلق منذ
سنوات لعدم تجديد التفويض وثمه معابر اخرى
مدنيه تجاريه كما تسمى هي اقل تجهيزا
كجرابلس والراعي والحمام
في الجانب التركي المنشغل بمصابه تثار
مساله الاضرار التي طاولت شبكه الطرق
باتجاه الحدود الجنوبيه مع سوريا لتفسير
بطء الجهد الاغاثي تبدو لافته للنظر دعوه
واشنطن مجلس الامن للموافقه الفوريه على
ارسال مزيد من المساعدات الدوليه الى
المنكوبين في شمال غربي سوريا عبر تركيا
وهنا ترى الامم المتحده الحله في فتح مزيد
من المعابر ونقاط ايصال المساعدات للاشد
حاجه اليها في الشمال السوري وتقول نائبه
المفرد الاممي الخاص الى سوريا نجاه رشدي
في تغريده على تويتر ان المساعده عبر
الحدود هي شريان الحياه للاشخاص في شمال
غربي سوريا وان السوريين بحاجه الى مساعده
عاجله
الطريقه الاخرى لادخال المساعدات
الانسانيه الاماميه هي ما يعرف بخطوط
التماس اظهرت جهود قليله بذلت في هذا
الاتجاه منذ وقوع الزلزال كيف ان العمليه
صعبه ومحفوفه بالمخاطر بالنسبه لنظام
السوري لا مشكله كما يقول في ايصال
المساعدات الانسانيه حتى الى المناطق
الخارجه عن سيطرته
كما يحددها المنسق الاممي للشؤون
الانسانيه في سوريا هي الحاجه الى موافقات
لدخول مناطق شمال غربي سوريا ليس جرافيث
اول مسؤول في الامم المتحده يتحدث عن عدم
السماح بادخال اي مساعدات في مناطق التماس
بين النظام والمعارضه ولا اول من امتنع عن
تحديد الجهات التي لم تصدر الاذن المطلوب
نشدت مندوبه الولايات المتحده الدائمه لدى
الامم المتحده ليندا توماس جرين فيلد مجلس
الامن الدولي المصادقه على فتح معبرين
اضافيين في سوريا خلال اجتماعه المغلقي
المقرر في وقت لاحق اليوم وقالت في لقاء
مع شبكه ام اس ام بي سي الاخباريه
الامريكيه الى تاخير فتح المزيد من
المعابر يعني موت مزيدا من ضحايا الزلزال
في سوريا
على مجلس الامن ان يتحرك بشكل عاجل لفتح
معبرين حدوديين اضافيين وقد سمعنا من منسق
الشؤون الانسانيه مارتن جرافيث ومن الامين
العام للامم المتحده انه من المهم ان نفتح
معابر اضافيه لذات على مجلس الامن التحرك
على الفور نامل ان نتمكن من تحقيق ذلك
ينضم الينا من نيويورك فرحان حق نائب
المتحدث باسم الامين العام للامم المتحده
مرحبا بك سيد فرحان
ماذا تريد الامم المتحده ان يخرج اليوم عن
جلسه مجلس الامن
في هذه المرحله ان مجلس الامن يحصل على
احاطه بالنسبه الى حجم الاحتياجات في
تركيا وسوريا وهناك حاجات مرتبطه بالقدره
على الوصول على وجه الخصوص من بين الامور
التي نوضحها هو ضروره الوصول الى الناس
الذين هم بحاجه بطرق اضافيه الالوان
المتحده في سوريا كانت تستعمل الخطوط خطوط
التماس للعبور ولكن في الاشهر الماضيه كان
فقط معبر باب الهوى والمعبر الوحيد
المفتوح هذا المعبر الان مفتوح وتم فتح
بعض الطرقات المؤديه اليه ولكن اذا ما كان
بالامكان فتح معابر اضافيه سوف ياتي ذلك
بفائده كبيره حيث ان الحاجات مرتفعه جدا
في الميدان في سوريا
هذا توجه في جلسه اليوم التوجه نحو فتح
مزيد من المعابر لايصال المساعدات الى
الشمال السوري
لا يمكنني ان اتوقع ما سوف تقرره الدول
الاعضاء في مجلس الامن ولكن من الواضح ان
الجميع في الميدان بما في ذلك كل الاطراف
في سوريا نفسها يودون ان يكون لديهم قدره
على الوصول بشكل اكبر ويودون منا ان نتمكن
من ايصال المساعدات ونحن نود ان نتمكن من
ايصال المساعدات ومن اجل حصول ذلك من
الجيد ان يكون لدينا اكبر عدد ممكن من
الطرق لايصال المساعدات للمنكوبين الذين
دمرت حياتهم بسبب هذا الزلزال ويحذون
الامل بان اعضاء مجلس الامن يقدرون مدى
الحاجه لاغاده اغاثه الناس ونحن نتحدث عن
ظروف استثنائيه ويجب ان تكون التدابير
استثنائيه للاستجابه فتح الطرق وهذه
المعابر هو المشكله الوحيده لانه لان
مارتن جريفيث بالامس يتحدث عن خذلان
الشعب السوري ما سبب ذلك سيد فرحان حق
امين
جزئيا المشكله هي عدم القدره على الوصول
الى الناس الذين هم بحاجه كمجتمع دولي نحن
بحاجه الى العمل بشكل افضل لفتح الطرقات
وازاله الانقاض واتخاذ كل الاجراءات
الضروريه للوصول الى الناس باسرع فرصه
ممكنه مضى اسبوع منذ حصول الزلزال ونحن
بحاجه
لايصال الطعام والماء والماوى والادويه
لكي يتمكن هؤلاء من الاستمرار في هذه
المرحله يجب ان ننتقل من جهود البحث
والانقاذ
المباشره ويجب ان نتاكد من تامين القدره
على الوصول وايضا الموارد من حيث التمويل
وانت ذكرت يعني انه مضى اسبوع
كما ذكرت مضى اسبوع سيد فرحان على وقوع
هذه الكارثه اليوم هناك انتقادات عن سبب
تاجيل انعقاد هذه الجلسه في مجلس الامن
امام هذه الكارثه الكبيره لاسبوع
وانعقادها اليوم بدل ان تعقد عندما حدثت
هذه المشكله هناك انتقاد لكم انتم في
الامم المتحده ومؤسسات الامم المتحده
بانكم لم تفعلوا كل ما بوسعكم لارسال هذه
المساعدات الى المتضررين
كنا نتحدث عن العاملين في حقل الاغاثه
الانسانيه هم يقومون بعمل جبار في الميدان
نحن نتحدث عن فرق ميدانيه تاثرت
بهذه الازمه بالتحديد
لدينا بعض الاشخاص الذين فقدوا بيوتهم
وكان لديهم ايضا خطر تعرضوا له هم سلامتهم
الشخصيه بسبب هذا الزلزال وبالتالي انا
فخور جدا بعملهم في الوقت نفسه اعضاء مجلس
الامن هم عباره عن دول خمسه عشره دوله
ويتعين علينا ان نحترم الوتيره التي من
خلالها تتوصل هذه الدول الى القرارات لان
هذه الدول هي التي تضع المبادئ التوجيهيه
التي على اساسها نقدم المساعدات اذا نحن
نقدم ولكننا ننتظر القرارات سيد سرحان
اريد ان الفت نظرك الى انه منذ بدايه هذه
منذ وقوع الزلزال دخل الى
مناط السوري حوالي 50 شاحنه فقط ان كانت
كل هذه المؤسسات والمنظمات تعمل لماذا
يدخل
هذا العدد الهائل من الناس المحتاجين
للمساعدات فقط هذا العدد الهزيل من
المساعدات عبر هذه الشاحنات هل لديك جواب
في الحقيقه في البدايه نحن بحاجه الى
الموارد ثانيا لا نتحدث عن منطقه لم تتاثر
ان جنوب تركيا قد تاثر بشكل كبير وهناك
ضرر كبير وفيات متعدده في تركيا وليس فقط
في سوريا لذلك نحن قدمنا المساعده لسلطات
التركيه بما في ذلك من خلال تنسيق جهود
البحث والانقاذ ولكن في الوقت نفسه نحن
بحاجه الى استخدام الطرق وهذه المناطق
لايصال المساعدات الى الناس في سوريا وفي
البدايه كان هناك بعض التحديات المرتبطه
بتامين الطرق من بلد الى اخر ولكن لسوء
الحظ كلا البلدين تاثرا بشكل كبير وهما
بحاجه الى مساعده دوليه هائله طبعا الازمه
والكارثه كبيره ايضا في تركيا كما ذكرت
ولكن باعتراف منظمات الامم المتحده الوضع
اكثر هشاشه واكثر خطوره في الشمال السوري
بسبب اصلا
الازمه السياسيه والامنيه التي كانت
موجوده هناك الان ما هو التوجه في المرحله
المقبله بالنسبه لهذا هذه الاعمال
الاغاثيه من اجل الوصول الى اكبر اعداد
ممكنه من المنكوبين
مساعدات اضافيه سوف تصل
من خلال معبر باب الهوى هذا ما حصل اليوم
السيد مارتن منسق الامم لشؤون الانسانيه
هو في سوريا والتقى بوزير الخارجيه
وبالرئيس الاسد وهو يحاول ان يؤمن طرق
اضافيه لتامين المساعدات بما في ذلك عبر
خطوط التماس من سوريا وقدم احاطه ويقدم
ريحاطه لمجلس الامن وسوف نرى مدى التقدم
الذي يمكن ان يحرز على مستوى مجلس الامن
التابع للامم المتحده وطبعا الامين العام
انطونيو يضغط بهذا الاتجاه دعم اضافي قدره
اضافيه على الوصول بما في ذلك لربما فتح
معابر اضافيه وسوف نرى ما هو التقدم الذي
يمكن ان نحرزه في الايام المقبله شكرا لك
فرحان حقا نائب المتحدث باسم الامين العام
للامم المتحده ضيفنا من نيويورك
حضرت اللجنه الدوليه للصليب الاحمر من ان
تؤدي اثار الزلزال الاخير الى تفاقم اوضاع
الاسر السوريه وقالت ان الحاجه الى
المساعده الطارئه في سوريا بلغت اعلى
مستوياتها على الاطلاق بعد 12 عاما من
الحرب المدمره وتدمير نصف المرافق الصحيه
اضافت ان العائلات السوريه تحتاج الى
الامدادات الاساسيه من غذاء وماوى وادويه
وانا تمويل العمل الانساني في سوريا منخفض
للغايه
تحذير الصليب الاحمر الدولي ياتي في وقت
تتفاقم فيه معاناه المتضررين من الزلزال
في جنديرس بريف حلب في شمال غرب سوريا
خصوصا مع الانخفاض الشديد في درجات
الحراره وعدم توافر خيام تخفف معاناتهم
مراسل الجزيره عمرو حلب ينقل لنا جانبا من
معاناه المتضررين في تلك المنطقه
ساضع الكاميرات اريكم كيف هو حال بعض
العائلات التي شردها الزلزال وهي بعض من
15 الف عائله شردتها الزلزال شمال غربي
سوريا فلنرى كيف هو مسكنهم واين ينامون
هنا ينامون
على العرش في العراء دون خيمه ودون اي شيء
هناك
هنا ينامون وهنا ايضا ياكلون هنا ماكلوهم
ومشربهم هذا ايضا مسكنهم اما تدفئتهم فهي
بعض من اغصان الزيتون التي يجمعونها من
هذه البساتين التي امامهم عشرات العائلات
في هذا المكان الذي نحن فيه جمال في ريف
جنديرس نقول جنديرس لانها وقبل ان تكلم عن
جنديرس ربما هذا الطفل الصغير هذا الطفل
الصغير انظر كيف ينام في العراء
[موسيقى]
هذا
هذا هو حال عشرات العائلات هنا
الله المستعان اخي
لا اعرف ان كان الكلام يكون ابلغ من هذه
الصوره جلال جمال لكن هذا هو وضع عشرات
العائلات ووضعها يشبه هذه العائلات التي
نقلنا لكم صورتها هنا قبل قليل على امتداد
هذا الطريق نحو كيلو الى اثنين كيلو متر
الرجال الصغار الكبار النساء يلتحفون
البطانيات من اجل ان تقيهم البرد ودرجه
الحراره الان هي صفر ومع ساعات الليل حسب
توقعات الى مادون الصفر ايضا
تنضم الينا من عمان بهيه زريكم مديره
وسياسه والمناصره في المجلس النرويجي
للاجئين مرحبا بك سيده بهيه كيف تتابعون
تداعيات واثار هذا الزلزال على الملايين
كينك شكرا على هذه الفرصه ما نقوم به الان
او اول ما قمنا به هو ان نتاكد من ان
زملائنا زملائنا والمتطوعين في سوريا هم
بامان
وما نحاول ان نقوم به هو الاستجابه
للحاجات في الميدان
نوزع الطعام والماء
ونؤمن ايضا بعض الاموال النقديه لكي يتمكن
الناس من شراء الاحتياجات الاساسيه ايضا
هناك حاجه للبطانيات لان الطقس شديد
البروده في سوريا وبالتالي نحاول ان ندعم
الى اقصى درجه ممكنه
تواجهكم في عملكم
التحديات الرئيسه هي بكل تاكيد ان
المساعده الانسانيه لا تكفي الان
على سبيل المثال منذ الزلزال الاول فقط
خمسه بالمئه من المناطق التي تاثرت بفعل
الزلزال وصلت اليها فرق البحث والانقاذ
وبالتالي
95% من المناطق التي تاثرت بالزلزال لم
تصل اليها فرق البحث والانقاذ وبالتالي
لسوء الحظ
95% من المباني حيث كان بالامكان ان نجد
احياء لم يتم البحث فيها وهنا هناك نقص
على كل المستويات على مستوى التمويل لكي
نتمكن من رفع مستوى الاستجابه لتوزيع طعام
اضافي وماء
وقود الموارد البشريه تنقص
الدعم ينقصنا على كل المستويات طبعا
تداعيات هذا الزلزال على الاسري والاشخاص
طويله الامد عندما نتحدث عن فقدان الماوى
عندما تتحدث عن فقدان افراد العائله كيف
يتم التعامل مع كل ذلك
بكل تاكيد تركز المنظمات على الحاجات
الملحه الان ونحاول ان نساعد الناس لكي
يصمدوا لكي يبقوا على قيد الحياه على
الاقل ماوى
وتقعد سبل التدفئه ولكن على الامد الابعد
سوف يكون من الاهميه بمكان ان يتم تقديم
شبكات من المساعده من خلال المستشفيات
والمدارس لكي يعود الناس الى حياه طبيعيه
بعض الشيء وايضا هناك حاجه
لاعاده العمل على صيانه المنازل لكي نتاكد
من عوده الناس الى نوع من الحياه الطبيعيه
ولكن هذا سوف يتطلب وقتا طويلا لانه
بالاضافه الى ذلك هناك صدمه نفسيه فظيعه
عانه منها ناس بعد سنين الحرب الطويله ها
هم يواجهون هذه الازمه والكارثه الانسانيه
الهائله لذلك هم بحاجه الى دعم من الجميع
ربما شاهدت معنا الصور التي عرضناها قبل
قليل من جنديرس في شمال سوريا كيف ان
الناس يعيشون ويبيتون في العراء منذ سبعه
ايام في ظروف سيئه جدا
شح في المواد الغذائيه شحف الادويه
درجات حراره منخفضه جدا كيف كيف يمكن
التعامل مع هذا الوضع
في الحقيقه ان الشعب السوري عبر او اثبت
انه لديه صلابه بعد اثنتي عشره سنه من
النزاع في اقصى
الظروف
وطبعا هذه القدره على الصمود للشعب السوري
في افضع الظروف
اثبتت ولكن الان ان الاوان لكي يدعم
المجتمع الدولي الشعب السوري كي لا يبقى
في هذه الظروف لفتره طويله ان الشعب
السوري عانى بما فيه الكفايه في السنوات
الماضيه والاوان قد نتاكد من ان الناس
يعني هذا معروف يعني المناشدات للمجتمع
الدولي بالتدخل ومساعده السوريين
متواصله منذ وقوع هذه الكارثه ولكن عمليا
على الارض كيف يمكن ايصال المساعدات كيف
يمكن ايصال الخيام كيف يمكن مساعده الناس
لان الوقت يمر والامور الى اسوا
بالنسبه الى المساعدات لكي تصل الى الناس
نحن بحاجه الى الحدود ان تبقى مفتوحه ونحن
بحاجه ان يسمح كل الاطراف
لايصال المساعدات الانسانيه للناس
المنكوبين الناس الذين هم بحاجه نحن بحاجه
الى المعابر ان تبقى مفتوحه والسماح للفرق
فرق الاغاثه الانسانيه
لكي يتمكنوا من الوصول من خلال كل السبل
المتاحه كل المعابر الممكنه كل الطرق
الممكنه ونحن بحاجه لكي يسمح الاطراف
الذين يسيطرون على هذه المناطق ان يسمح
لنا للقيام بعملنا شكرا لك بهيه ذريكي
مديره سياسه والمناصره في المجلس النرويجي
للاجئين ضيفتنا من عم
ان هذا وتصل جثمين مئات الضحايا من
السوريين الذين قضوا جراء زلزالي في مناطق
جنوبي تركيا الى مناطق شمال غرب سوريا عبر
معبر باب الهوى وقال المكتب الطبي في
المعبر ان الجانب التركي سلم اكثر من 1300
قتيل مع توقعات بارتفاع اعداد الضحايا
السوريين في تركيا بعد انتهاء عمليه البحث
والانقاذ وبدء مرحله انتشال الضحايا
[موسيقى]
عند معبر باب الهوى الحدودي بين سوريا
وتركيا ينتظرون ذويهم من الضحايا الذين
قضوا في الزلزال بمناطق تركيا
واخرون ينتظرون خبرا عن ذويهم المفقودين
اما ابو سامي فجلس وحيدا مفجوعا في اقرباء
كانوا على قيد الحياه انه تحت الانقاض
يسمع صوت انيمهم
يلا راح نوصل لك يلا راح نجيب لك مي راح
نوصل لك
يلا يا رب يا حمدو
لم يكن اي جثمان من ذويه بين الضحايا
عايش اموره تمام اخذوه بالطياره على اضنه
سالنا عن امه واخته واهله قلنا لهن تحت
الانقاض وتوفوا من القهر ما تحمل توفى
مباشر على الخبر حسبي الله ونعم الوكيل
وهلق عم نستناهم في المعبر لحتى ناخذه على
الدفن
[تصفيق]
ينتظر ابو سامي بينما تمر الجنازات كانت
جنازه لجثامين عائله قضت بكاملها
تسلم ذو الضحايا جثامين العائله وذهبوا
الى جبل الزاويه بريف ادلب الجنوبي
تتوالى صلوات الجنائز منذ اليوم الاول
للزلزال في معظم مناطق شمال غربي سوريا
سبع سنين طبعا في اطفال ما شافت هاي
الضيعه ولا بتعرف هاي الضيعه شو هي
توفوا كمان الله يرحمه يعني استشهد
العدد الاجمالي 12 شهيد سبعه مرعش طبعا
اللي هناك اولاد اخوته
وعنا خمسه بانطاكيا
دفنت عائله ابو محمد في بلدتها ولكن مئات
الضحايا من دمشقى وحمصه وحلب دفنو شمال
سوريا بعيدا عن مسقط راسهم ابناء الوطن
واحد تفرقوا لاجئين في تركيا
وقدوا في زلزال واحد فرت عائله ابو محمد
من الحرب الى تركيا منذ سنوات ها هم
يعودون اليوم الى سوريا ضحايا تشلوا من
تحت ركام زلزال كهرمان مارش بعد ان لاحقهم
الموت بعيدا في منفاهم
ادهم ابو حسام الجزيره ريفوت
معنا من ريفي ادلب برائد الصالح مدير
الدفاع المدني مرحبا بك سيد رائد الصالح
بينما نتحدث مع بعض هناك جلسه لمجلس الامن
لدراسه كيفيه ايصال المساعدات الى
المتضررين من الزلزال في تركيا وفي الشمال
السوري انتم ما هي مطالبكم الان من
المجتمع الدولي
تحياتي المشاهدين حقيقه مطلبنا الاساسي هو
عدم عقد هذه الجلسه
لا يجب ان تعقد مجلس الامن جلسه لايصال
مساعدات متضررين زلزال هذا خذلان كبير
للسوريين هناك يعني هم يقولون الامم
المتحده يتحججون بانه حسب القانون الدولي
يجب ان ياخذون تصريح ههه او قرار من مجلس
الامن ولكن هناك دراسات من اكاديميين
وحقوقيين
ودوليين وعاملين سابقين حتى في الامم
المتحده في المكتب القانوني في القانوني
واصدر دراسه بال 180 صفحه تقول بانها
الامم المتحده لا تحتاج الى قرار مجلس
الامن لايصال المساعدات الى شمال غرب
سوريا
ههه لذلك انا ما احتاجه من المجتمع الدولي
فعليا هو عدم عقد هذه الجلسه والبدء فعليا
بارسال المساعدات الى سوريا من جميع
المعابر المتاحه للوصول هذا ما نحتاجه
فعليا المجتمع الدولي اذا كان جاد فعليا
بالاستجابه للكارس الانساني بعد مرور
ثمانيه مشكله سيد رائد هي في
المعابر انه لا يوجد سوى معبر واحد مفتوح
بين تركيا وسوريا والتعقيدات اللوجستيه
بسبب الطرق ام ان المشكله انه لا يوجد
اساسا مساعدات لكم
حقيقه يعني هناك كثير من الدول تحدثت عن
المساعدات ويبدو انه يوجد مساعدات يعني
يبدو انه يوجد مساعدات ولكن
قرار مجلس الامن او الامم المتحده لا
معبر باب الهوى لذلك ولكن هناك دول
استخدمت
معبر هذه المعابر هي المعابر مفتوحه ليست
مغلق ولكن قرار مجلس الامن ينص على
استخدام معبر باب الهوى يعني تستطيع يعني
مثلا دوله قطر والسعوديه
والطيب كردستان وغيرها ارسلت مساعدات عبر
باب السلامه وهذا لا مانع يعني هم لا
يحتاجوا انا لا اعلم لماذا يعني انا سمعت
يعني مره خبر عاجل قليل عندكم بان المندوب
الفرنسي ان علاء بشار الاسد هل ننتظر نحن
موافقه بشار الاسد لعبور المساعدات لنا
وهو الذي قصفنا بالكيماوي وقسطنا
بالبراميل المتفجره وضحت فكرتك الان الان
سيد رائد وضحت فكرتك الان لو تعدد لنا
ابرز الاحتياجات في المنطقه في هذه
المرحله ما هي
نحن الان في مرحله
الانتقال يعني انتهيت تقريبا انتهينا وحسب
المعطيات لم يتبقى جثث او
جساميل للاشخاص تحت الانقاض
الان بمرحله الثانيه واللي هي
تقديمه عائلي موجودين الان في العراق نحن
يجب ان نتكلم في هذا الامر الاولويه
الاولى هي تامين الثانيه هي التدفئه ثالث
الطعام والمياه والرعايه الطبيه هؤلاء هذه
الاولويات التي يجب العمل عليها وبشكل
عاجل عاجل جدا جدا جدا يعني دعني اقول
الماوى والتدفئه نحن في ظروف الشتاء الان
ايضا اذهب الى ذلك الطعام والشراب
والرعايه الطبيه الشراب مهم جدا في
هذه مهم جدا والماء النظيف حصرا لماذا
لانه اصلا مخيمات الشمال السوري كانت
تعاني من الكوليرا قبل الزلزال الاولويه
الثانيه هذه
الاولى للعائلات التي تركت بيوتها
الاولويه الثانيه هي ان نبدا نحن كفرق
دفاع مدني سنبدا بازاله الانقاض وفحص
الابنيه من خلال تشكيل لجنه هندسيه لجنه
مهندسين بالتعاون مع نقابه المهندسين
سيتم تقييم كافه المباني الغير الصالحه
للسكن والغير صالحه للسكن وبعدها
سيتم ازاله المباني الغير صالحه للسكن
وازاله الانقاض الاولويه الثالثه هي تامين
منازل
للمتضررين في من الزلزال حقيقه هذه ترتيب
الاولويات الان في
رائد الصالح اريد فقط ان انوه الى هذه
الاخبار العاجله التي ظهرت على شاشتنا
المندوب الفرنسي في الامم المتحده يقول
انه على نظام السوري السماح بوصول
المساعدات الان او سنعمل على تمرير قرار
دولي ويضيف نحتاج مساعده الامم المتحده
والمنظمات غير الحكوميه لتقديم الاغاثه
الى شمال سوريا ويقول ايضا لا اعتقد اننا
مستعدون للتفاوض مع نظام السوري فيما
يتعلق
بالعقوبات نعود الى موضوع المساعدات سيد
رائد بعد ان عداد ما هي ابرز الاحتياجات
لديكم ماذا عن كيفيه تلقي هذه المساعدات
في ظل الوضع الراهن الان
كيفيه تلقيها ومن هي الجهات المسؤوله عن
توزيعها وكيفيه ايصالها الى المحتاجين
هناك كثير من المنظمات السوريه العامله في
شمال غرب سوريا هناك الخبز البيضاء هناك
منظمات احسان المنتدى السوري سانز اوسوم
كمنظمات طبيه هناك ايضا منظمات كالقلب
الكبير وغيرها من منظمات بنفسج وهناك كثير
من المنظمات حقيقه التي تعمل على ايصال
المساعدات وهناك وهذه المنظمات لديها
شراكات مع الامم المتحده ولديها شراكات مع
الدول لذلك يعني حتى هناك مؤسسات موجوده
كالهلال الاحمر القطري كان اليوم يوزع
مساعدات القطر الخيري ايضا كانت توزع
مساعدات منظمه الامين بالتعاون مع مركز
الملك سلمان كانت توزع مساعدات حقيقه ان
وجدت المساعدات هناك اليات للعمل هناك طرق
هذه المنظمات عملت على مدار السنوات
الطويله جدا وهي تتمتع بالمصداقيه
والشفافيه وقادره على ايصال هذه المساعدات
لمستحقيها بشكل كئيب
شكرا لك رائد الصالح مدير الدفاع المدني
السوري كنت ضيفنا من ريف ادلب
نجح فريق الانقاذ القطري اليوم في اخراج
رجل فالعقد السادس من العمر حيا من تحت
الانقاض في ولايه هاتاي في اليوم الثامن
على الزلزال
[موسيقى]
وضمن تداعيات هذا الزلزال المدمر في تركيا
تبرز الحاجه في مناطق الكوارث الطبيعيه
لمستشفيات ميدانيه فهي تلعب دورا كبيرا في
مراحل الاستجابه الاولى خصوصا لتداعيات
الزلزال الذي ضرب مناطق عده في تركيا
وسوريا فريق الجزيره واكب عمل احد هذه
المستشفيات في محافظه ادمايا الديامان
الجنوبيه تركيا وتعرف عبر احد طواقمه على
جهود الفرق الطبيه في اسعاف المصابين جراء
تلك الكارثه وطبيعه الاصابات
اصابه جديده تصل الى المستشفى الميداني
وعلى الدكتور قدري ان يقف على حالتها
وصلت هذه السيده للتو علينا ان نشخص
اصابتها اصابتها تبدو حديثه وقعت على
الارض وبدات حجاره الحائط تتساقط فوقي
يذهب المسعفون بالسيده للعلاج هنا في واحد
من المستشفيات الميدانيه في اديامان التي
انشات كاستجابه طارئه لزلزال كهرمان مراش
دليلنا الطبيب المسؤول عن المستشفى
واذا كانت الاصابه بالغه ننقل المصابين
جوا الى مستشفيات اكثر تجهيزا
في المدينه المنكوبه تستمر الحالات
بالتوافد هذا الشاب نجا من تحت الانقاض
وفرق والده وبعض اقاربه الحياه
كنت في الطابق الثاني عندما انهار المنزل
وبدا الحطام يتساقط فوقي وفي غرفه ثانيه
رجل مصاب يبحث عن ابنته
فقدت ابنتي ولا استطيع ايجادها وزوجتي في
العنايه الفائقه
يسمح لنا الطبيب بتفقد غرفه العمليات في
المستشفى الذي ساهم في انقاذ عشرات
الارواح في المدينه وهنا تساؤل هل يمكن
للطواقم الطبيه ان تبقى خارج نطاق التاثر
بحجم الماساه المحيطه بهم
نشعر بمعاناتهم بالماساه لكننا يجب ان
نتصرف بمهنيه عاليه بعيدا عن مشاعرنا
نترك الطبيب وفريقه ونسمع بينهم همسات قلق
على عائلتهم البعيده وعن المستقبل القريب
وصف مشهد الدمار العظيم في المدن المنكوبه
اذا تعمل الاف الفرق الطبيه بصمت حاولنا
التعرف على قليل مما يقومون به ليبقى
الجهد الاكبر لهؤلاء متجليا في قصص ملايين
الناجين من الزلزال سلام خضر الجزيره
الديامون
رصدت كاميرا الجزيره اعمال ازاله الالقاب
والبحث عن ناجين في ولايه هاتاي التركيه
وقد لحقت بالولايه خسائر بشريه وماديه
جسيمه وتعتبر من بين اكثر ولايات البلاد
تضررا من الزلزال
كقطعه من قطع الدومينو تهاوى هذا المجمع
السكني الشهير في محافظه هاتاي جراء
الزلزال مئات العائلات كانت تقطن في هذا
المجمع الضخم الذي اشتهر بعد اعتقال
الشرطه في مطار اسطنبول المتعهد الذي بناه
[موسيقى]
تجمع عينات من هيكل البناء المتناثر لعلها
تفيد التحقيقات في شبهه الغش في مواد
البناء
كثيرون فارقوا الحياه هنا يمر الوقت ثقيلا
على من نجى من الفاجعه
علاء وادهم مهندسان اخواني جاء الى تركيا
بعد انقطاع التواصل مع اقارب لهما كانوا
يعيشون هنا
يشتكى الاخوان قله عدد الفرق الاحترافيه
ورابطان هنا خشيه ان تخرج جثه ما دون
القاء نظره عليها للتاكد من هويه صاحبها
بدنا نطالع جسسهم وندفنهم للاسف ما في اي
مساعده ما في اي تنصيب نحن جاهزين انه
نساعد وكل الناس موجودين جاهزين انه
يساعدوا وانا بشهد انه الفرق الموجوده
قادرين على هذا الشيء لكن للاسف ما في
تنظيم وهذا هو الجرح اللي نحن عم ننجرحه
كل يوم انه لو في تنظيم للعمل نحن قادرين
انه نطلع جثث اكثر من من 500 شخص موجود
غير بعيدا عن المجمع يعيش في هذه الخيمه
ما بقي من عائله كان عددها كبيره
قاسيه هي الحياه اليوميه في الخيام يزيدها
حده نقص الخدمات في مثل هذه الظروف
لا نعرف ما الذي سيحصل غدا خرجنا بلا شيء
لا توجد مشكله في الطعام فهو يصلنا لكن
نحتاج الى خدمات كدورات المياه والاضاءه
ليلا لو حل هذا الامر يمكن ان نتدبر امرنا
بضعه اشهر
تتواصل اعمال رفع الاوقات وازاله الركام
الى ان يتم التاكد تماما من عدم وجود ناجم
او جثه ترقد تحت وطاطها تعد هاتاي واحده
من اكثر المحافظات تضررا بالزلزال مع اكثر
من 2000 مبنى تحول الى كومه من الركام ولا
يختلف حالها عن حال محافظات اخرى شرد فيها
الناس وهاموا على وجوههم او هلكوا تحت
الانقاض
المعتز بالله حسن الجزيره
في تركيا عن الدوري البارز الذي تطلع به
هيئه الكوارث والطوارئ التركيه افاد لكن
الكارثه ستشكل في الان نفسه اختبارا
للمؤسسه التي انشات عام 2009 المزيد في
التقرير التالي
هيئه الكوارث والطوارئ التركيه المعروفه
اختصارا بافاد هي مؤسسه اغاثه تاسست عام
2009 واسندت اليها مهمه تنسيق جهود البحث
والانقاذ وتقديم المساعدات في الزلازل
والفيضانات وحرائق الغابات وغيرها من
حالات الطوارئ وعواقبها اصبحت افاد منذ
عام 2018 تابعه لوزاره الداخليه التركيه
بعد ان ظلت سنوات تحت اشراف رئيس الحكومه
طنشه المؤسسه داخل تركيا وخارجها حيث
اطلعت بدور اساسي خلال زلزال ازمير عام
2020 وفيضانات منطقه شمال البحر الاسود
عام 2021
وخارجيا نسقت افاد جهود اغاثه مختلفه لا
سيما في شمال شرق سوريا تضم المؤسسه اكثر
من سبعه الاف عنصر ينتشرون في نحو 80
ولايه تركيه لكنها ايضا تستقطب متطوعين
بلغ عددهم بعد الزلزال الاخير نحو 700 الف
متطوع وقد اصبحت افاد في السنوات الاخيره
اكثر انتشارا واقرب الى محتاج خدماتها اذ
وضع التطبيقات طوارئ للابلاغ عن الحوادث
كما عززت شركتها مع عده جهات اغاثه خارجيه
عبر اتفاقيات تعاون وستشكل كارثه الزلزال
الاخير وتبعاتها اختبارا مهما لمؤسسه افاد
من حيث قدرتها على الاستجابه السريعه
للكوارث الكبرى ونجاعه دورها
من انقره ينضم الينا الدكتور ابراهيم
التان المدير العام للهلال الاحمر التركي
مرحبا بك دكتور ابراهيم لنبدا من موضوع
استمرار انتشال بعض الاحياء من بين الحطام
والركام ركام الابنيه ماذا يقول لنا هذا
الامر وكيف تشعرون عندما يحدث ذلك
هذا الامر يقولنا
انتبهوا
لانشاء البناء انشاء البناءكم ولا تبنوا
بنيات ضعيفه ابدا ابدا
نعم ولكن السؤال هو عن استمرار وجود احياء
بعد سبعه ايام بعد اسبوع على وقوع هذه
الكارثه هذا هذا الموضوع اي امل يبعثه
لديكم لدى العائلات
انا استشرت مع طبيب طبيب قلت قلت له كيف
يعيش الولد طفل
عمره
شهران منذ
ثمانيه ايام كيف يعيش
واجاب الان نحن نتناقش بين بين الاطباء
هذا الامر هذا الشيء كيف صار والان يدور
يدور النقاش بيننا
والحمد لله طبعا عند الزلزال عند الزلزال
يصير بعض الاماكن في
الانقاد هناك
مناطق امنه
يعطي الفرصه
شو اسمه يقتل فرصه حياه
للشخص وبعض بعض الناس
وصلوا الى الى الماء للطعام
يعني وجدوا فرصه حياه الحمد لله الله عز
وجل اعطاهم فرصه حياه وطبعا كلما اثر شخص
حيا والناس كلهم
كلهم
ينظرون هناك
ينتظرون هناك اشخاص اخرى
يعني هذا الامر يزرع امل بين قلوب
المتضررين من الزلزال
والسكان تركيا كامله طيب دكتور ابراهيم
اين وصلت الان مرحله الانقاذ ما الذي
انجزتم منها وماذا يبقى
تركيا تركيا طبعا لها كوادر في انقاذ
الناس في شو اسمه في الزلزال وايضا طلبت
من العالم الكوادر
لانقاذ الناس شو اسمه في الانقاذ وجاءت
الاف كوادر
للعمل في الانقاذ نحن لدينا فريق صغير
ولكن نحن مكلف بتغذيه الناس في الكوارث
نحن
بعد بعدما صارت الزلزال
والكوادرنا مراكزنا مباشره وصلوا الى الى
المناطق الى اشرف مدن وبدانا ان نوصل
المتضررين والعاملين
الغذاء الماء وما شابه ما يحتاج اليه
العامل والمتضرر
والان في هذه المرحله بعد انقضاء اسبوع
تقريبا على وقوع الزلزال ما التركيز ما
التركيز في هذه المرحله في عمليات الاغاثه
الان الان شو اسمه نحن بدانا ان نقيم
المخيمات مخيمات لكي يسكن المتضررين في
المخيمات وينتقلون من الشوارع من بين من
حول بيوتهم الى المخيم
ويجد فرصه حياه هناك
يعني يصل الى الطعام مطبوخ ويصل الى الى
الراحه يصل الى الصحه وينتبه الى صحته بعد
ذلك
بعد ايام ان شاء الله كل المتضررين
سينتقلون الى المخيمات
نحتمل انهم سيبكون في المخيمات حوالي سته
اشهر او ثمانيه اشهر وبعد ذلك سينتقلون
الى بيوت مسبقه الصنع ان شاء الله
سنكتفي بهذا القدر اشكرك جزيل الشكر السيد
ابراهيم التان الدكتور ابراهيم التان
المدير العام للهلالي الاحمر التركي كنت
ضيفنا من انقره
[موسيقى]
منتصف الليل بتوقيت مكه المكرمه هذا
التذكير باهم العناوين في هذه التغطيه
المباشره
مجلس الامن يبحث في جلسه مغلقه لدعم
مندوبي زلزال في تورك في سوريا بعد اسبوع
من سجلات عرقله وصول المساعدات المتحدث
باسم الامم المتحده يقول للجزيره ان
الحاجه ماسه لفتح معابر جديده وايصال
مساعدات عبر خطوط التماس ومن البرلمان
الاوروبي دعوات للامم المتحده لاقامه جسر
جويا عاجل
[موسيقى]
وفي الشمال السوري الاف المشردين في ريفاي
حلب وادلب يواجهون في العراء شحه
المساعدات وتعثر الاغاثه ودرجات حراره تحت
الصفر ومع مشهد كارثه واسعه النطاق
المنشات الصحيه تواجه اعباء غير مسبوقه
والصليب الاحمر يقول ان الحاجه الى
المساعده الطارئه في سوريا بلغت اعلى
مستوياتها منذ 12 عاما
وفي تركيا انتشال احياء من تحت الانقاض
بعد اكثر من 180 ساعه على الكارثه ورغم
تضاؤل فرص العثور على احياء فرق انقاذ
محليه ودوليه تكثف جهودها وتسابق الزمن
وتقارير تقدر خسائر زلزال تركيا باكثر من
84 مليار دولار
قال الامين العام للامم المتحده انه يرحب
بقرار الرئيس السوري بشار الاسد بفتح
نقطتي عبور باب السلامه والراعي من تركيا
الى شمال غرب سوريا لفتره اوليه مدتها
ثلاثه اشهر للسماح بتسليم المساعدات
الانسانيه وكانت مصادر دبلوماسيه قد قالت
ان وكيل الامين العام لشؤون الانسانيه
مارتن ابلغ مجلس الامن الدولي ان النظام
السوري وافق على السماح للامم المتحده
باستعمال معبرين حدوديين اضافيين بين
تركيا وسوريا لادخال المساعدات الانسانيه
اضافت المصادر ان ايصال المساعدات الى
سوريا عبر هذين المعبرين سيستمر لمده
ثلاثه اشهر
معنا من مقر الامم المتحده في نيويورك
مراسل الجزيره مراد هاشم مراد ماذا في
التفاصيل وما الذي رشح عن هذه الجلسه
نعمل في هذه الجلسه لا تزال متواصله حتى
الان ومما تسرب منها ما قاله
مارتن جرافيث للاعضاء من انه تلقى موافقه
النظام السوري على فتح معبرين اضافيين هما
معبر باب السلامه وبعبر باب الراعي على
الحدود التركيه السوريه لادخال المساعدات
الانسانيه الى مناطق الشمال الغربي السوري
وهذا يعني ان مجلس الامن الان اعفي من
معركه خوض اعتماد مشروع قرار جديد لاقرار
هذه الاقرار المعابر الاضافيه لانه اذا
كان النظام السوري لم لم يقدم هذه
الموافقه كان سيتعين اصدار مثل هذا القرار
لكن مع ذلك هناك معلومات تشير الى ان بعض
الاعضاء مع ذلك يحبذونه
ان يصدر قرار من اجل وضع هذه المعابر في
صيغه قانونيه
اكثر موثوقيه بطبيعه الحال الامم المتحده
الان
ثبت انها كانت في وضع صحيح حينما كانت
تتحدث عن
نقاشات ايجابيه مع النظام السوري بهذا
الشان وكان مارتن جريفيث يحث اعضاء مجلس
الامن الدولي على الانتظار اي منحه فرصه
اكبر
للتفاوض مع النظام السوري من اجل اقناعه
بهذا الامر وبالتالي اعفاء مجلس الامن من
الخوض معركه حول قرار جديد لمجلس الامن
الدولي السفير الفرنسي وكذلك السفير
البريطاني قبل هذه الجلسه ادليا بتصريحات
في الواقع شديده اللهجه السفير الفرنسي
قال انه اذا كان النظام السوري يريد
بالفعل فتح معابر حدودها الى شمال الغربي
سوريا فانه كان سيفعل منذ بدء هذه الكارثه
قال مره اسبوع واكثر من اسبوع والنظام
السوري السوري لم يقدم اي اشاره على ذلك
وملوحا بقرار تحت السابع من اجل اعتماد
هذه الممرات وحينما سئل اما اذا كان ماذا
سيفعل المجلس اذا استخدمت روسيا حقا نقض
الفيتو قال انه ان ذلك سيكشف ان روسيا لا
تلقي بالا واهتماما
مساله
تدور السوريين من الجوع او تجويع السوريين
كما قال وانها بذلك ستحمل المسؤوليه اذن
من الواضح ان الامور تتجه
بهذا على هذا المنحه اي بقرار او بدونه تم
اعتماد هذين المعبرين
والامين العام للامم المتحده اصدر بيانا
يرحب بهذه الخطوه وقال ان هذا سيتيح في
الواقع قدره اكبر على ايصال مساعدات
انسانيه بحجم اكبر وبطريقه اسرع
وسيسهل المعاملات والاجراءات مشيرا الى ان
الامم المتحده تحديدا هو يقصد في بيانه
الصندوق المركزي للطوارئ تلقى خمسين مليون
دولار اضافي بطبيعه الحال كان الصندوق
علنا
تخصيص 50 مليون دولار لمساعدات في سوريا
الان هذا الصندوق تلقى تبرعات ومساهمات من
عده الدول بينها الولايات المتحده وفرنسا
وهو هولندا
واليابان من اجل عمليه الاغاثه وهذه بادره
تؤشر تعتبرها الامم المتحده ايجابيه بشان
مساله التعاطي الدولي والاستجابه الدوليه
لدعم عملياته الانسانيه المتوقعه عن تزداد
وتتكتف خلال المرحله المقبله هناك
دبلوماسيون ايضا
الى ان المساله الان بعد الموافقه بعد
موافقه النظام السوري سيكون المساله
مرهونه بالتنفيذ اي تنفيذ تم
التعهد به بطبيعه الحال
المسؤوليه التنفيذ السؤال
باختصار مراد يعني بالنسبه للامم المتحده
الان بعد صدور هذا البيان الترحيبي من
الامين العام هل هذا يعني انه بالنسبه
للامم المتحده بالامكان استخدام هذه
المعابر بطريقه شرعيه لادخال المساعدات
صحيح
وفقا لاغلب التفسيرات الامم المتحده الان
لا تحتاج الى موافقه مجلس الامن لا تحتاج
الى قرار من مجلس الامن للسماح بادخال
المساعدات الى الشمال الغربي السوري دون
اذن من النظام السوري كما هو الحال في
الاليه عبر باب الهوى الان النظام السوري
وافق على دخول المساعدات عبر معبرين
اضافيين بطبيعه الحال الى جانب معبر باب
الهوى وبالتالي لا حاجه هناك للاعتماد هذه
المساله او لقرار ان اراد المجلس الا يصدر
قرار وبالتالي الامم المتحده تستطيع ان
تتحرك ومع ذلك قد يصار الى اعتماد قرار من
اجل المزيد من الموثوقيه
ابقى معي مراد هاشم مراسلنا من مقر الامم
المتحده في نيويورك سننتقل مباشره الى عمر
الحوراني الموجود عند معبر باب السلامه في
روسيا حلب عمر
هذا المعبر كان شهد دخول بعض المساعدات
اليوم
قربنا اكثر من المشهد
والحركه عند هذا المعبر
نعم بدايه هذا هو معبر باب السلامه هو احد
المعابر التي تم الموافقه على ادخال
المساعدات منها بهذا القرار هو معبر
الراعي هنا نود الحديث على ان المعضله
الاكبر لا تكمن بالموافقه على ادخال هذه
المساعدات فمعبر باب الهوى موجود لكن هذه
المساعدات لم تاتي ما اتى العشرات
السيارات وهي لا تكفي ولا تغطي هذه الحاجه
اليوم والمعضله هو بعدم توفر هذه
المساعدات لا يوجد مساعدات خلف الحدود
تنتظر هذا القرار لكي تدخل هناك نقص
بالامدادات في دخول هذه المساعدات لكن هذا
القرار يسهل على الامم المتحده ادخالها
عبر قرار عبر قرار
اليه عبر اليه ادخال عبر الحدود لكن الدول
والمساعدات خارج الامم المتحده المقدمه من
الدول تستطيع في اي وقت كانت ان تدخل
المساعدات عبر هذه المعابر والدليل على
ذلك انه دخل من معبر باب الى الحمام سته
شاحنات فيها 90 طن مقدم من المملكه
العربيه السعوديه وايضا من هذا المعبر دخل
اليوم 13 شاحنه بالاضافه الى منذ يومين
دخل
14 شاحنه مقدمه من كردستان العراق هذه
المساعدات بمجملها بما فيها ايضا 52
شاحنه دخلت عن طريق معبر باب الهوى
بمجملها لا تغطي شيء من حاجه هذه المنطقه
وايضا نتحدث عن تاخر في دخول هذه
المساعدات خلال الايام الاولى كانت
المنطقه بحاجه الى هذه المساعدات كانت
المنطقه بحاجه الى الى معدات ثقيله في
حديث اليوم للائتلاف تحدث عن ان هذه
المعدات لو توفرت للدفاع المدني لكان حجم
الخسائر اقل من ذلك بكثير كون كان هناك
نقص بالمعدات كما انه كان نقص بالكوادر
البشريه اذا الان هو حاجه لمعدات وحاجه
للاغذيه هذا هذه الفتره لا لا يوجد حاجه
لفرق
باختصاصات محدده لا يوجد حاجه للعنصر
البشري الحاجه اليوم لمعدات كما تحدثنا
لاكمال رفع الانقاض كما ان هناك حاجه
للمواد الغذائيه هناك حاجه للتجهيزات
الماوى حيث ان الاف العائلات مازالوا
يفترشون
يفترشون العراء جراء هذا الزلزال هناك ما
يقارب اكثر هناك اكثر من 1700 مبنى مدمر
بشكل كامل هناك اكثر من
الاف مبنى هي ايله للسقوط هذه المباني
وسكان هذه سكان هذه المباني هم يبيتون منذ
حدوث هذا الزلزال خارج
منازلهم دون تامين ماوى لهم دون تامين
غذاء لهم كافي وذلك يعني
ونعود ونكرر بان الائتلاف قد
يعني حدد مسؤوليه الامم المتحده عن هذا
العجز وقال بان الامم المتحده قدمت
المساعده للنظام بما احجمت عن تقديم
المساعده لمناطق سيطره المعارضه شماليه
غربي سوريا وهذا الامر الذي فاقم من
معاناه السكان السكان هنا بشكل كبير الذين
ما زالوا كما ذكرنا يباتون ليلتهم في
العراء وفي السيارات اذا توفر لهذه
العائلات السيارات
لك من معبر باب السلامه في ريف حلب مراسل
الجزيره عمر الحوراني وشكرا لمراسلنا من
مقر الامم المتحده في نيويورك مراد هاشم
شكرا لكمما
قال فرحان حق نائب المتحدث باسم الامين
العام للامم المتحده ان فرق الاغاثه
التابعه للمنظمه الدوليه تبذل جهودا كبيره
على الارض لاغاثه المنكوبين من الزلزال
وبشان الاتهامات بالتقصير في الاستجابه
للازمه قال حق في مقابله مع الجزيره بان
الامم المتحده تقدم الاحاطات مطلوبه
بالنسبه لتداعيات الزلزال لكن القرارات
تبقى بيد الدول الاعضاء بمجلس الامن
اذا ما كنا نتحدث عن العاملين في حقل
الاغاثه الانسانيه هم يقومون بعمل جبار في
الميدان نحن نتحدث عن فرق ميدانيه تاثرت
بهذه الازمه بالتحديد
لدينا بعض الاشخاص الذين فقدوا بيوتهم
وكان لديهم ايضا خطر تعرضوا له هم سلمتهم
الشخصيه بسبب هذا الزلزال وبالتالي انا
فخور جدا بعملهم في الوقت نفسه اعضاء مجلس
الامن هم عباره عن دول خمسه عشره دوله
ويتعين علينا ان نحترم الوتيره التي من
خلالها تتوصل هذه الدول الى القرارات لان
هذه الدول هي التي تضع المبادئ
التوجيهيه التي على اساسها نقدم المساعدات
كما اكد حق في مقابلته مع الجزيره ان
مساعدات اضافيه في طريقها للشمال السوري
وان المحاولات حثيثه لايصالها عبر خطوط
التماس مؤكدا الحاجه الى فتح معابر اخرى
الى جانب معبر باب الهوى نظرا لظروف
الاستثنائيه التي يمر بها الشمال السوري
هناك حاجات مرتبطه بالقدره على الوصول على
وجه الخصوص من بين الامور التي نوضحها هو
ضروره الوصول الى الناس الذين هم بحاجه
بطرق اضافيه الالوان المتحده في سوريا
كانت تستعمل الخطوط الخطوط التماس للعبور
ولكن في الاشهر الماضيه كان فقط معبر باب
الهوى والمعبر الوحيد المفتوح هذا المعبر
الان مفتوح وتم فتح بعض الطرقات المؤديه
اليه ولكن اذا ما كان بالامكان فتح معابر
اضافيه سوف ياتي ذلك بفائده كبيره حيث ان
الحاجات مرتفعه جدا في الميدان في سوريا
بدوره قال المندوب الفرنسي في مجلس الامن
الدولي نيكولادو ريفيار ان على المجلس
تحمل مسؤولياته وتسهيل الاغاثه الانسانيه
للجزء الشمالي من سوريا واشار للحاجه الى
مساعده الامم المتحده ووكالاتها او
المنظمات غير الحكوميه لتقديم الاغاثه
الانسانيه وقال انه كان بامكان نظام الاسد
منذ وقوع الزلزال السماح باستعمال معابر
حدوديه اضافيه اذا اراد واستبعد المندوب
الفرنسي في مجلس الامن الاستعداد للتفاوض
مع النظام السوري فيما يتعلق بالعقوبات
واضاف ان هناك خيارين احدهما ان تمنح
الحكومه السوريه حق الوصول او يتعين على
مجلس الامن تمرير قرار تحت الفصل السابع
لفتح نقاط عبور حدوديه اضافيه
وكانت مندوبه الولايات المتحده الدائمه
لدى الامم المتحده ليندا توماس قد ناشدت
مجلس الامن الدولي المصادقه على فتح
معبرين اضافيين في سوريا خلال اجتماعه
المغلق وقالت جرين فيلد في لقاء مع شبكه
ام اس ان بي سي الاخباريه الامريكيه ان
تاخير فتح المزيد من المعابر يعني موت
مزيدا من ضحايا الزلزال في سوريا
على مجلس الامن ان يتحرك بشكل عاجل لفتح
معبرين حدوديين اضافيين وقد سمعنا من منسق
الشؤون الانسانيه مارتن جرافيث ومن الامين
العام للامم المتحده انه من المهم ان نفتح
معابر اضافيه لذا فعل مجلس الامن التحرك
على الفور نامل ان نتمكن من تحقيق ذلك
يجري هذا الحراك دبلوماسي في نيويورك في
وقت تثير فيه ازمه المساعدات ودخولها الى
المناطق المنكوبه في الشمال السوري نقاشا
كبيرا وجدلا حادا وعلى وقع الانتقادات لما
يوصف بتقصير المجتمع الدولي جاء اجتماع
مجلس الامن الدولي
محنه فاخرى ما ابقته الحرب نسفه الزلزال
ترتبط المحنتان ايضا في كون الاولى اوجدت
واقعا في الشمال السوري عقد تبعات التاليه
حتى قبل ان تهتز الارض هنا كان ما يزيد
على اربعه ملايين شخص بتقدير الامم
المتحده بحاجه الى المساعدات والان تتعثر
جهود ايصال ما يلزم من مساعدات انسانيه
الى المتضررين من الزلزال في حينها ودون
عوائق
الامم المتحده نفسها تقر بالفشل في ايصال
المساعدات الحيويه مع ان لديها اليه واضحه
في هذا الشان
ففي مناطق سيطره المعارضه السوريه
المحاذيه لتركيا مع براني حدوديه رئيسيه
هما باب الهوى في ادلب وقد جدد مجلس الامن
شهر الماضي التفويض الامميه لدخول
المساعدات عبره سته اشهر اخرى
ومعبر باب السلامه في ريف حلب المغلق منذ
سنوات لعدم تجديد التفويض وثمت معابر اخرى
مدنيه تجاريه كما تسمى هي اقل تجهيزا
كجرابلس والراعي والحمام
في الجانب التركي المنشغل بمصابه تثار
مساله الاضرار التي طاولت شبكه الطرق
باتجاه الحدود الجنوبيه مع سوريا لتفسير
بطء الجهد الاغاثي تبدو لافته للنظر دعوه
واشنطن مجلس الامن للموافقه الفوريه على
ارسال مزيد من المساعدات الدوليه الى
المنكوبين في شمال غربي سوريا عبر تركيا
وهنا ترى الامم المتحده الحله في فتح مزيد
من المعابر ونقاط ايصال المساعدات للاشد
حاجه اليها في الشمال السوري وتقول نائبه
المنفذ الاممي الخاص الى سوريا نجاه رشدي
في تغريده على تويتر الى المساعده عبر
الحدود هي شريان الحياه للاشخاص في شمال
غربي سوريا وان السوريين بحاجه الى مساعده
عاجله
الطريقه الاخرى لادخال المساعدات
الانسانيه الاماميه هي ما يعرف بخطوط
التماس اظهرت جهود قليله بذلت في هذا
الاتجاه منذ وقوع الزلزال كيف ان العمليه
صعبه ومحفوفه بالمخاطر بنسبه لنظام السوري
لا مشكله كما يقول في ايصال المساعدات
الانسانيه حتى الى المناطق الخارجه عن
سيطرته
لكن المشكله كما يحددها المنسق الاممي
للشؤون الانسانيه في سوريا هي الحاجه الى
موافقات لدخول مناطق شمال غربي سوريا ليس
غريفيث اول مسؤول في الامم المتحده يتحدث
عن عدم السماح بادخال اي مساعدات في مناطق
التماس بين النظام والمعارضه ولا اول من
امتنع عن تحديد الجهات التي لم تصدر الاذن
المطلوب
معنى من غازي عنتاب الياس ابو عطا المتحدث
الاقليمي باسم لجنه الانقاذ الدوليه مرحبا
بك سيد الياس الان وقد او اودعنا نسال هل
هي هل المشكله في ايصال المساعدات الى
سوريا كانت في موضوع
مسار وصول هذه المساعدات اي هذه المعابر
التي يجري اليوم الاعلان عن فتحها ام ان
المشكله هي في عدم وجود هذه المساعدات من
الاساس
مساء الخير سيد عائلتي شكرا للاستضافه في
البدايه يجب ان نقر او نعترف بان هذه
كارثه طبيعيه ولكن واقعها كان كبيره جدا
على المستوى على مستوى المنطقه بشكل عام
فهي الاكبر من خلال هذه هذا مئه سنه لنقول
ونزلنا حتى الان حتى انا في غازي عنتاب في
جنوب تركيا وهذا المنطقه التي كان فيها
مركز او بؤره الزلزال يجب ان اقول بانه
قبل ساعتين بالتحديد شعرنا بهزه اخرى
فدخلنا في الاسبوع الثاني وما زال هناك
اكثر من 2500 هزات ارتداديه تجري وتحصل
نشعر بالبعض منها ولا نشعر بالبعض الاخر
فهي كارثه هي كارثه بالفعل كازمه كارثيه
ولكن بالنسبه للامم المتحده وحتى المنظمات
الانسانيه كان هناك تحديات كبيره على ارض
الواقع في الميدان وجهها زملائنا في
الميدان ففي البدايه نقول ببعض التحديات
كان هناك طقس البارد كان هناك الدمار
الناتج عن هذه الزلزال كالطرق والجسور
والبنى التحتيه التي تدمرت واثرت على وصول
العمال الاغاثه الى الارض والمساعده في
عمليات البحث والانقاذ والى اخره فعنا
هنالك عمليات بحث وانقاذ هناك عنا عمليات
تعافي ومساعدات الناس الذين نزلوا من هذا
الزلزال فلذلك لا نستطيع القول بان هناك
سبب واحد لماذا كان هناك بطء في سير
المساعدات ووصولها الى الميدان ولكن
نستطيع ان نقول بان المعبر الحدودي الوحيد
الذي تستطيع ان تستخدمه علوم المتحده وهو
معبر باب الهوى كان في البدايه يعاني من
صعوبه وصول مساعدات تكفي جميع الناس الذين
هم في حاجه في شمال غرب سوريا لدينا اربعه
اكشن اربعه ملايين شخص 90% منهم يحتاجون
الى مساعده انسانيه فلم تكن المساعدات في
الوقت انذاك اي قبل الزلزال تكفيها هؤلاء
الناس او هؤلاء الفئات ولكن الان مع
الزلزال فقد ارتفعت هذه الاحتياجات هذه
الاحتياجات بطريقه الان هي سيد الياس من
المنظمات منظمات التي تعمل في مجال
الاغاثه هو
مضيء اكثر من اسبوع على وقوع هذه الكارثه
ومع ذلك عدم ايجاد حلول لهذه الازمه
المتفاقمه المتمثله بايصال المساعدات هل
ترى ان الامر سيختلف في المرحله المقبله
الان
لاعاقب عن عن قرار الذي سمعناه الان من
حضراتكم على التلفاز حول اجتماع مجلس
الامن الدولي فلجنه القاده الدوليه
بالنسبه لنا ولاعمالنا في سوريا وفي تركيا
نعتقد او لنقول الان نتحدث عن سوريا في
التحديد هذه خطوه ايجابيه بالطبع ونحن
نرحب بها لانها بالنسبه لنا ما تعنيه بانه
يمكن زياده حجم المساعدات بشكل كبير الان
ووصولها الى السوريين بغض النظر عن مكان
تواجدهم يعني سنحتاج الى ولكن سنحتاج
للتاكد بان هذه الطريقه فعاله
ان نتاكد بان المعبرين الاضافيين
يمكن عن طريقهم الوصول الفعال غير المقيد
الى الفئات الموجوده في المناطق التي يمكن
ان يصلها او تصل عن طريق هذا المعبر
الان
ما هي احتياجات الاكثر الحاحا لا سيما
للسكان في الشمال السوري
حاليا ينظر الى الموضوع من جانب انساني ما
يجب عليه هو امرين البدايه استمرار عمليات
البحث والاغاثه وهي وهذا امر صعب جدا في
الجانب السوري بسبب عدم وجود اليات كثيره
وفعاله تستطيع بالقيام بعمليات البحث كما
كنا نشاهده على الطرف الاخر وهو الطرف
التركي
فالاحتياجات صعبه بالنسبه للشعب المتواجد
في جانب شمال سوريا اما ان هذه بالنسبه
لعمليات البحث والانقاذ هناك ايضا عمليات
الاغاثه لمن تم انقاذهم او حتى الذين لم
يتضرروا لنقول بشكل القوي الذي رايناه
ولكن ايضا هناك ناس بحاجه فهناك اكثر من
100 هناك 100,000 مئات الالاف للاشخاص
عفوا لا استطيع ذكر الرقم بالتحديد ولكن
الاحتياجات فائقه في في الجانب السوري وهم
بحاجه في البدايه الى ماوى منهم من فقد
منزله زملائنا في ارض الميدان من لجنه
النقاط الدوليه تضر منازلهم منهم من فقد
احبائه منهم من فقد روحه وللاسف خسرنا
اثنين من موظفينا في الجانب السوري وكان
هدف امر طبعا صعب للغايه علينا اجمعين في
المنظمه
فاولئك من خسروا منزلهم بحاجه الى ماوى في
البدايه اضافه الى طعام
ومياه نظيفه للشرب واغاثه طبيه فالوضع
النظام الصحي في شمال سوريا كنب متدهور
حتى قبيل هذا الزلزال والان الوضع اصبح
بحاجه ناسه الى مساعده سريعه شكرا لك
الياس ابو عطا المتحدث الاقليمي باسمي
لجنه الانقاذ الدوليه ضيفنا من غازي عنتاب
القى تقرير وحده تنسيق الدعم في شمال غرب
سوريا الضوء على حجم الدعم المطلوب لتلبيه
الاحتياجات الانسانيه الطارئه الناجمه عن
الزلزال نستعرض في التقرير التالي هذه
الاحتياجات بالارقام
كشف حجم الدمار الهائل في ادلب وحلب
وجنديرس والاتارب عن احتياجات لوجستيه
عاجله حيث دمر في تلك المناطق
677 مبنى بشكل كامل بينما بلغ عدد المباني
الايده للسقوط
653 مبنى بالاضافه للحاجه الى 104 فرق
لدعم الدفاع المدني ومئه وسته عشره شاحنه
لنقل الركام
و145 ضاغط هواء واشار تقرير وحده تنسيق
الدعم الى ضروره توفر 65 جرافه و66 اليه
حفر واضاف ان هناك احتياجات تموينيه عاجله
ايضا للنازحين تشمل مئه الف وجبه طعام
يوميا
و160 الف غطاء بالاضافه الى اكثر من خمسه
عشر الف خيمه واكثر من سته ملايين لتر من
وقود التدفئه لمواجهه البرد القارس
وقد مرت سبعه ايام على وقوع زلزال كهرمان
مرش الذي ضرب مناطق عده في جنوب تركيا
وشمال غرب سوريا حيثما تزال عمليات البحث
والانقاذ مستمره في عدد من المناطق بينما
تم الاعلان عن انتهائها في اماكن اخرى
ويحصي البلدان حجم الخسائر التي خلفها هذا
الزلزال المدمر والتي تجاوزت سته وثلاثين
الف قتيل حتى الان في اسوا كارثه انسانيه
تعيشها المنطقه خلال مئه عام
اسبوع مره على زلزال كهرمان مراش بايامه
وساعاته الطوال مضت كئيبه على العالقين
تحت الركان وعلى المشردين والناجين في
الساحات والشوارع والخيام
وعلى فرق الانقاذ التي تسابق الزمن في
مهمه
تتوقف على نجاحها حياه الناس هنا حيث اقف
جنوب تركيا بدا كل شيء هزه شديده تبعتها
اخرى لم تعترف بحدود السياسه ولا بحواجز
اللغه فوحدت بين الاتراك والسوريين في
الماساه وتركتهم يلملمون الجراح عند
الرابعه وسبعه عشره دقيقه من فجر الاثنين
السادس من فبراير شباط هكذا بدت الصوره
حجب غزق الليل حجم الدمار وما هي الا
سويعات حتى تكشف ما احدثته الهزه من ادرار
ويا له من دمار دقائق قليله دمرت شوارع
باكملها وبدلت ملامح مدن وغيرت جغرافيه
المكان حصيله قتلى بعشرات الالاف وملايين
المشردين
مئه وثمانون ثانيه تخلخلت فيها طبقات
الارض فعبثت بحياه الملايين وتساوى فيها
الناس في محنتهم ومبيتهم وماكلهم تسارع
عداد القتلى بدا بالمئات وما لبث ان قفز
الى الالاف من
الشعب التركي يعيش اقصى ايام تاريخه
الزلزالان الكبيران الديائل اضرار كبيره
جدا في عشر محافظات تركيه تضم نحو 13
مليون ونصف مليون مواطن تركي خبراء
الزلازل وصفوا الزلزالين بانهما
استثنائيان ولا مثيل لهما في العالم عند
مقارنه هذين الزلزالين باشباههما فانهما
الديال حدوث شقوق ارضيه في منطقه جغرافيه
واسعه جدا وهو ما ادى الى تعاظم الدمار
الدمار الهائل ذاته امتد الى الشمال
السوري تزامن مع منخفض جوي قارس البروده
ونقص شديد في معدات البحث والانقاذ
زاد من معاناه السوريين المكلومين بويلات
الحرب تعقيدات السياسه وما نظر اليه على
انه بخل من المجتمع الدولي وتاخر في ارسال
المساعدات على قلتها على ضفتي الحدود
تتشابه قصص الضحايا والناجين وان اختلفت
ظروف الدولتين وامكاناتهما في اسوء كارثه
تضرب المنطقه منذ قرن من الزمان
ما حدث هنا في بؤره الزلزال هو اسوا حدث
تشهده المنطقه خلال مئه عام
اجبر زلزال مئات الالاف من الاتراك على
المبيت في العراء واصبحت الحكومه ومعها
جيش من المتطوعين راعيا لابسط حاجياتهم من
اكل وشرب ووسائل تدفئه وفي سوريا اعاد
الزلزال الى الاذهان مشاهد النزوح بعد
تدمير حلبه وادلب ليس بالبراميل المتفجره
هذه المره لكن بسبب قوه قاهره لا تقبل
التفاوض
تقاطعت على تركيا قوافل المساعدات وفرق
الانقاذ ونهجه الالسن بالدعوات وبثروات
المتضامنين في حين كان الشمال السوري اقل
حظا واقل استقبالا للدعم وهذا باعتراف
الامم المتحده التي قالت ان المجتمع
الدولي خذل السوريين في تصريح لم يكن
مفاجئا
[موسيقى]
يا الله
بعد مرور اسبوع لم تتوقف عمليات الانقاذ
فرق بحث تغلب التعب وتثابر رغم قسوه الطقس
وقله النوم مجهود كوفي بانتشال الرضع
والشيوخ وما بينهما من اعمار في كابه
المشهد وسوداويته قصص ملهمه تطفي لمسه
انسانيه جميله ونبيله على صوره حزينه
رسمها الزلزال
فتدعيته ستبقى محفوره في ذاكره اجيال
بكاملها وندوبه العميقه ستبقى باديه لكن
للبشر قدره عجيبه على التاقلم ونفض الغبار
والمضي قدما والعوده من جديد
كارما المراش
من غازي عنتاب ينضم الينا مراسل الجزيره
منتصر ابو نبوت منتصر بعد
حوالي اسبوع على وقوع هذا الزلزال ماذا
بقي من جهود الانقاذ وماذا عن اوضاع
الناجين
الجهود الانقاذ لا تزال مستمره حتى هذه هي
اللحظه في ولايه غازي عنتاب وفي الولايات
التركيه الاخرى التي ضربها هذا الزلزال لم
تتوقف الامل يعني لا يزال موجوده لدى فرق
الانقاذ بالرغم من الايام الطويله التي
مرت على الاشخاص الذين هم عالقين تحت
الانقاذ لكنهم يعني متاملين من خروج بعضهم
على قيد الحياه وهذا ما يتعمله الجميع على
العموم
الان المشهد يرتسم في قضيه النازحين وهذه
القضيه التي تسعى ولايه غازي عنتاب الى
حلها
من خلال انها ارسلت فرق متخصصه الى
الابنيه لفحصها وتفحصها وبعد ذلك
تحديد الاضرار التي وقعت على هذه الابنيه
ولايه غازي عنتاب قالت اليوم ان نحو 80%
من الابنيه في الولايه تم فحصها وتم
التحقق من سلامتها
نصبتها افاد في الاصلاحيه في الملعب
الاصلاحيه هناك خمسه الاف خيمه وايضا في
نورداغ بالاضافه الى مدينه غازي عنتاب لكن
هناك اشخاص اخرين لديهم خيام صنعوها
بانفسهم في محاوله
لتلقي هذا البرد نحن الان نشهد درجات
حراره منخفضه هي ما دون الصفر نشاهد هذه
احد
المخيمات التي يعني صنعها الاهالي بانفسهم
في محاوله لتدارك هذا البرد هذه احدى
الحدائق مثلا الموجوده بالقرب من بلديه
شاهين في مدينه غازي عنتاب والتي هي يعني
كما نشاهد حاولوا استقلال بعض المقاعد
وحاولوا نصب القيام من خلال استخدام ما
يعرف بالشوادر او
البلاستيك في محاوله منهم يعني تدفئه
ابنائهم هذا كل مكان يوجد فيه اكثر من
عائله قد يتواجد في نفس هذا في نفس هذه
الخيمه اكثر من عائله على العموم هذه
الخيام هي جانب من
توزع الاهالي هنالك اشخاص في سياراتهم
هناك اشخاص غادروا ولايه غازي عنتاب ولكن
الوضع قد يعني يعني بدا يتكشف وبدات
المحليه بدات تتخذ اجراءات جديده متعلقه
بكارثه هذا الزلزال وهنا يجدر اشاره ايضا
الى ان مدينه اصلاحيه ومدينه نورداخ قد
يعني يهدى بشكل كامل لان جميع المنازل
فيهما مدمره وهي ضمن الابنيه التي تحدثنا
عنها في بدايه هذه المداخله اشكرك من غازي
عنتاب منتصر ابو نبوت مراسلنا من هناك
شكرا جزيلا لك
على صعيد عمليات الانقاذ والاغاثه نجح
فريق الانقاذ القطري اليوم في اخراج رجل
في العقد السادس من العمر حيا من تحت
الانقاض في ولايه هاتاي في اليوم الثامن
على الزلزال
وفي ولايه هاتاي ايضا تمكن فريق انقاذ من
انتشال امراه وابنتها على قيد الحياه بعد
مرور 160 ساعه من وقوع زلزال مدمر ووفقا
لوكاله الاناضول فان الطفل لينا البالغه
من العمر 11 عاما انتشلت مع امها وهما على
قيد الحياه من تحت ركام عمارتهم المنهاره
ونقلت بعدها الى المستشفى لتلقي العلاج
اللازم
وضمن تداعيات هذا الزلزال المدمر تبرز
الحاجه في مناطق الكوارث الطبيعيه
لمستشفيات ميدانيه فهي تلعب دورا كبيرا في
مراحل الاستجابه الاولى خصوصا لتدعيه
الزلزال الذي ضرب مناطق عده في تركيا
وسوريا فريق الجزيره واكب عمل احد هذه
المستشفيات في ولايه اديوان جنوبيه تركيا
وتعرف عبر احد طواقمه على جهود الفرق
الطبيه في اسعاف المصابين جراء تلك
الكارثه وطبيعه الاصابات
اصابه جديده تصل الى المستشفى الميداني
وعلى الدكتور قدري ان يقف على حالتها
وصلت هذه السيده للتو علينا ان نشخص
اصابتها اصابتها تبدو حديثه وقعت على
الارض وبدات حجاره الحائط تتساقط فوقي
يذهب المسعفون بالسيده للعلاج هنا في واحد
من المستشفيات الميدانيه في اديامان التي
انشئت كاستجابه طارئه لزلزال كهرمان مراش
دليلنا الطبيب المسؤول عن المستشفى
واذا كانت الاصابه بالغه ننقل المصابين
جوا الى مستشفيات اكثر تجهيزا
في المدينه المنكوبه تستمر الحالات
بالتوافد هذا الشاب نجا من تحت الانقاض
وفرق والده وبعض اقاربه الحياه
كنت في الطابق الثاني عندما انهار المنزل
وبدا الحطام يتساقط فوقي وفي غرفه ثانيه
رجل مصاب يبحث عن ابنته
فقدت ابنتي ولا استطيع ايجادها وزوجتي في
العنايه الفائقه
يسمح لنا الطبيب بتفقد غرفه العمليات في
المستشفى الذي ساهم في انقاذ عشرات
الارواح في المدينه وهنا تساؤل هل يمكن
للطواقم الطبيه ان تبقى خارج نطاق التاثر
بحجم الماساه المحيطه بهم
نشعر بمعاناتهم بالماساه لكننا يجب ان
نتصرف بمهنيه عاليه بعيدا عن مشاعرنا
نترك الطبيب وفريقه ونسمع بينهم همسات قلق
على عائلاتهم البعيده وعن المستقبل القريب
وصف مشهد الدمار العظيم في المدن المنكوبه
اذا تعمل الاف الفرق الطبيه بصمت حاولنا
التعرف على قليل مما يقومون به ليبقى
الجهد الاكبر لهؤلاء متجليا في قصص ملايين
الناجين من الزلزال سلام خضر الجزيره
الديامون
معنا من اسطنبول وموت
الشرق الاوسط في هيئه الاغاثه الانسانيه
التركيه مرحبا بك
كيف تصف هذه المرحله الان من عمليات
الاغاثه التي تقومون بها وما هو التركيز
تحديدا
على ماذا تركزون تحديدا
مساء الخير اولا نريد ان نشكركم على نشر
هذه لكل مشاهدين طبعا التركيز هنا كانت في
البدايه على الفرق الانقاذ طبعا الان قللت
العمل في هذا المجال بسبب ان كثير من
المباني الان بدا يتم ازالتها وما زالت
البحث الانقاذ يستمر في كثير من المباني
التي
يدقق حتى في النهايه يتاكد من ان ليس في
احد في قيد الحياه لكن الان التركيز الاول
المؤسسات الحكوميه ومؤسسات غير الحكوميه
كائها نحن نركز على ما يتعلق بالايواء لان
الان كما نعرف العدد الاحصائيات اليوم
الطلعه ان 33,000 من المباني
تهدمت بالجزء كبير وهذا طبعا غير ما تهدمت
من المباني الكلي ف الان مئات الالاف من
الاشخاص الان في العراق في مناطق مختلفه
وفي شوارع على حسب امكانياتهم لكن الاول
الذي ما نركز نحن نت
ابع المناطق التركيه عبر شبكه مراسلين
نشاهد في العديد من المدن بعض الناس الذين
تمكنوا من الوصول الى او الحصول على خيم
والاحتماء بها في هذا الطقس البارد وايضا
في نفس الوقت وفي نفس تلك المدن نشاهد
اشخاص لم يتمكنوا من الحصول على ذلك
يعيشون اما في سياراتهم اما في الحدائق
العامه ما المعايير هنا يعني من الذي تمكن
من الحصول على خيمه وماذا ايضا عن
الاحصاءات في هذا المجال
يعني طبعا الان ما يتعلق بالخير هو العدد
النقص فيها كثيره جدا
فان يركز على الاسر الذي في لهم اطفال
الصغار الذي يتاثر كثير من البرد لكن لا
يعني الان مئات الاف الذي يحتاج الى الخيم
لكن نحن كمؤسسات المانحيه لغير الحكومين
نركز اكثر على غير الخيام نركز على الان
ان نرسل الى المناطق ما هو يسمى بالبيوت
الجاهزه التي يركب بشكل سريع
ويليق ان يعيش فيها الاسره فهذا ما تركز
فيها الحكومه والكمان المؤسسه غير
الحكوميه لان الان يتوقع ان ان تجلس هؤلاء
الناس على الشوارع في هذه الحاله سنه وسنه
ونصف طبعا جزء منه يسكن
هذه البيوت الجاهزه الى اي مدى يمكن لهذه
المساحات ان تستوعبها في ظل الحجم الكبير
من السكان الذين فقدوا منازلهم نحن نتحدث
عن الملايين
طبعا
ليست الملايين على الشوارع لان جوز كبير
منهم كما يعني الحكومه صرحت بالبعض
الاتفاقيات مع الفنادق ومع السكن الطلاب
فلذلك لان الحكومه قامت باجازه الجامعه
وقامت بقرار ان تكون الجامعه التعليم عن
بعد فلذلك يستخدم كمان السكن الطلاب لكن
العدد الاحتياجات في هذا المجال الكبير
البيوت الجاهزه
يسكن فيها سنه وسنه ونصر اكثر لانه
يعني
اقوى من الخيم نستطيع ان نقول ان اقوى من
الخيام بكثير ولكن ليس
البيوت الخرسانه لكن مع ذلك الاحتياجات
كبيره فالان اتفق مع كثير من المصانع في
سواء كانت داخل تركيا او خارج تركيا
فلان يتوقع ان تكون المصنع يصرف هذا العمل
هذا شكرا من اسطنبول ومت مسؤوله وعلاقات
الشرق الاوسط في هيئه الاغاثه الانسانيه
التركيه
من اسطنبول ايضا ينضم الينا البروفيسور
نزاد ترهان الطبيب النفسي ورئيس جامعه
اسكودار سيد البروفيسور نزاد ترهان طبعا
اثار نفسيه هائله بسبب هذا الزلزال على
معظم السكان في تركيا وشمال سوريا لو
اردنا ان نعدد هذه الاثار ماذا تقول
نعم بالنسبه الى الاثار النفسيه
يمكننا ان نتحدث عن زلزالين قويين في
تركيا حصل
والوقت الفاصل بينهما كان حوالي تسع ساعات
وهناك
صدمات نفسيه متعدده
تولدت بسبب ذلك
ويمكننا ان نتحدث عن ثلاث مراحل اولا
الصدمه الاوليه
بعض الاناناس
يتاثرون من خلال تغير سلوكهم
لايام طويله
افكارهم تصبح مشتته
ونظراتهم تصبح فارغه البعض الاخر من الناس
قد يتحول الى
العدوانيه في السلوك
والبعض الاخر من الناس
يتاثر بهذه الاضطرابات والصدمات بحيث
يتوقف عن الحركه بشكل شبه كلي
هذا ما رايناه
بعد
الزلزلين
والهزات التي حصلت
بالنظر الى هذه الاثار التي عددتها الان
المرحله الاولى من التعامل تتم عبر
المسعفين ورجال الانقاذ
والمستشفيات الميدانيه على الارض هل لديك
نصيحه لهؤلاء العاملين في كيفيه التعامل
مع السكان الذين يعانون من هذه الاضطرابات
التي عدتها
المساعده
الاساسيه للناس الذين يعانون من اضطرابات
ومن صدمه
تقضي بعدد ترك هؤلاء لوحدهم وتقديم
المساعده المساعده لهم
يجب ان لا نشكك
بشعورهم ويجب ان لا نطرح عليهم الاسئله
بشكل متكرر ماذا حصل ولماذا تشعر بهذا
الشعور او ذاك اشكرك
نزاد ترهان الطبيب النفسي ورئيس جامعه
اوسكو دار ضيفنا من اسطنبول
مدن كبيره وبلدات في تركيا غيب اهلها تحت
الانقاض وتغيرت معالمها حتى تشابهت من
اتساع الدمار الذي خلفه زلزال كهرمان مرش
السلطات التركيه بدات تحصي بشكل اولي
اضراره على الابنيه السكنيه والتجاريه
وغيرها وتفصل حاله كل بناء والقبليه لعوده
شاغله وسكانه او للاصلاح او للهدم بشكل
عاجل هذه الاحصائيه الاوليه لحجم الاضرار
وما تعنيه من اثار حاليه ومستقبليه في
التقرير التالي
منكوبه هي تلك الولايات التركيه التي
ضربها زلزال كهرمان مراش بتاريخها
وعمرانها وطرق كسب اهلها وقبل ذلك واهم
منه باهلها انفسهم من مات منهم ومن نجا
قد تقرب صوره الدمار وتداعياته على
الاتراك في تلك الولايات ما احصته مبدئيا
مديريه شؤون البناء التابعه لوزاره البيئه
التركيه
فماذا تقول الجرده حساب احصت نحو خمسه
من الاضرار التي لحقت بولايه العشر التي
ضربها الزلزال في تلك الولايات
7619 بناء يجب هدمها بشكل عاجل ويتضاعف
الرقم في الابنيه التي اصيبت بضرر كبير
الى
12,705 وتشمل هذه الاحصائيه البيوت
والمكاتب والمؤسسات التجاريه
بنظره سريعه تبدو ولايه غازي عنتاب وهاتاي
وملاطيا صاحبه الارقام الكبرى حتى الان من
تلك الابنيه الواجب هدمها بسرعه عوده
الضرر الكبير الولايات الثلاث الغازي
عنتاب وهاتاي وملاطيا على سبيل المثال
يقطنها وفق الاحصاءات الرسميه اكثر من
اربعه ملايين تركي يضاف لهم مليون سوري
كثير من هؤلاء خياراتهم ضئيله ومحصوره
باتجاه ترك مناطقهم ولو مؤقتا والتوجه الى
ولايات اخرى بحثا عن السكن واستمرار
الاعمال والتعليم وغير ذلك هذه الارقام
الاوليه قد تفسر وتقرب ما كان ذكره الرئيس
التركي رجب طيب اردوغان في وقت سابق بان
المتضررين في المناطق المنكوبه ومحيطها قد
يصلون الى نحو 20 مليون مواطن تركي
[موسيقى]
ينضم الينا من عمان الدكتور محمود
القريوتي الباحث والمختص في علمي ورصد
الزلازل مرحبا بك دكتور محمود ما دلالات
استمرار الهزات الارتداديه
مساء الخير لك ولجميع المشاهدين وشكرا على
الاستضافه نعم يعني
الدلاله الكبيره ان هذا النشاط
حقيقه مستمر حيث بدا بنشاط قوي جدا
فازلزال 7.8
كبدايه لهذا النشاط هو بدايه عاصفه عنيفه
حقيقه ضربه المنطقه نعم
الدلاله على ذلك ان هذا النشاط مستمر
وهكذا هي العواصف عاده تبدا بشده ومن ثم
تبدا
بانخفاض في القوه وفي العدد
بدايه اول اول ايام هذه العاصفه حقيقه حدث
حدثت عده زلازل تفوق ست درجات لا تقل عنها
الى سبعه الى ثمان درجات
وهي مستمره لغايه الان حاليا يعني حدود
القوه من
ونص الا خمسه في تقدير سوف يستمر هذا
الحال الى الى الى فتره معينه لكن سوف يقل
شيئا فشيئا طبعا هذا هذا متوقع محمود
القريون في اعتقادك يمكن ان تستمر عليها
هذه
الهزات الارتداديه خصوصا ان هيئه رصد
الزلازل في تركيا تتحدث عن امكانيه
استمرارها لعام كامل ربما من بعد الزلزال
الكبير
نعم نعم هذا حقيقه متوقع لا يقل عن اشهر
ولربما عن عام عن عام كامل لكن هناك
ملاحظه
ان الزلازل قد تستمر لكن الاحساس قد يكون
اقل معنى ذلك انها سوف تستمر على قوه اقل
من خمسه تقريبا
طبعا هذا نشاط متذبذب لربما بعد فتره
معينه قد يحصل زلازل نوعا ما متوسطه من
اربعه ونصف الى خمسه اكثر ذلك بكثير لكن
مع الوقت سوف يقل شيئا فشيئا الى محمود في
هذه الظروف حتى لو كانت الهزات الارتداديه
تقل حدتها كيف ينعكس استمرارها كل هذه
الفتره على اولا جهود اعاده اعمار تلك
المناطق التي تقول السلطات التركيه انها
تريد ان تقوم بها وايضا على
ما يجري حاليا من محاولات ايواء لسكان
الذين فقدوا منازلهم خصوصا وان عمال
الانقاذ يتحدثون الان عن محاولات لنشر
البيوت الجاهزه في تلك المنطقه عمليا هل
يمكن السكن فوق هذه المناطق ان كانت لهزات
الارتداديه مستمره
حقيقه يعني عمليه
الاظهار وكذلك
والسكن فيها مواجهه حقيقه وذلك
لكثير لوجود كثير من الابنيه والمنشات
الهندسيه تضررت كثيرا ولربما لم تسقط ولم
تهدم كاملا فلربما بعض
الهزات او الارتدادات نعم تعمل شيئا ما في
في الضرر على هذه المباني وهذه المنشات
فالعمليه حقيقه يعني بالغه الصعوبه وفيها
تعقيد لكن لكن لربما
لكن لربما التقييم الاولي للمباني الايل
للسقوط لربما يعطي فكره مدى مدى تحملها
وبالتالي يمكن التعامل معها بشكل حذر
ثم ثم هذه الزلازل كما ذكرت قد تؤثر فعلا
على هذه المباني لكن يعني كما اسلفت لربما
تقل حدوتها شيئا فشيئا
اشكرك دكتور محمود القليوطي الباحث
والمختص في علمي وراس للزلازل ضيفنا من
عمان
وقبل استئناف تغطيتنا المستمره لزلزال
تركيا وسوريا وتداعيته المختلفه نعرج على
جديد الاوضاع في الاراضي الفلسطينيه
المحتله فقد هدمت قوه الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
ثلاثه منازل لفلسطينيين في بلده جبل
المكبر في القدس المحتله بدعوى البناء دون
ترخيص واصيب اكثر من ثلاثين فلسطينيا
نتيجه اعتداء جنود الاحتلال بالاعيره
المطاطيه وقنابل الصوت والغاز بينهم مصور
الجزيره الزميل وائل سلايمه الذي اصيب
بعيار مطاطي في قدمه
بينما تعمل الجرافات لازاله الركام وانقاذ
الارواح في مكان اخر بالعالم تحول جرافات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي بيوت الفلسطينيين في
القدس الى ركام هنا يجد الفلسطيني نفسه
امام سلطه تمنع عنه تراخيص البناء وفي
الوقت ذاته تهدم له بيته بحجه البناء دون
ترخيص وفي حاله ابو ادهم تهدم له ولابنائه
ثلاثه منازل في وقت واحد
وكله من تعبنا وشكانا يعني احنا احنا
جماعه بنشتغل قصدين باب الله
والكرش بعز علينا والشجر بعز علينا وتعبوا
اولادنا برضه والوقت الحالي احنا مشردين
يعني بالعربي فش مسكن
قوات كبيره طوقت المنطقه وحاصرت العائلات
وخلال عمليه الهدم كانت تقمع سكان الحي
وتعتدي عليهم ورغم ضجيج الهدم وصوت
القنابل ظل صوت اصحاب المنازل مسموعا
ان بعد ان انهت عمليه تدمير المنازل دقائق
قليله استغرقها هدم كل منزل وتشريد اصحابه
مقابل سنوات من العمل ليتمكن اصحابها من
بنائها وايواء عائلاتهم
ولتامين انسحابها قامت قوات الاحتلال
باطلاق الاعيره المطاطيه وقنابل الغاز
المسيل للدموع ما ادى الى اندلاع مواجهات
مع الشبان الفلسطينيين اوقعت عددا من
الاصابات من بينها اصابه مصور الجزيره
الزميل وائل السلايمي في استهداف مباشر
للاطقم الصحفيه
الاف المنازل يتهددها الهدم في القدس
المحتله بذريعه عدم الترخيص ومع تهديدات
الحكومه الاسرائيليه الحاليه بتكثيف
عمليات الهدم يزداد شعور الفلسطيني بانه
وحيد في معركه غير متوازنه يواجه فيها كل
انواع السلاح والتهجير بعلاقته مع الارض
نجوان سمري الجزيره من بلده جبل المكبر
القدس المحتله
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا الكرام انتهت هذه الجوله
الاخباريه اشكر لكم متابع